I think taxing the wealthy taxing people
at the higher end of the economic
spectrum is not the right way to go I
think what's happening is if we're not
very careful is that big businesses you
know have a parasitic relationship with
the state ubers net contribution was
five hundred pounds per year that's it
that is wrong I think I never got into
business to to rack up numbers to to win
awards or to do anything like that I
think what you were is private and it's
not something to go shouting around
because every every job every career is
different what I do is you know is no
more important than somebody else who
could be anything far less than me it's
to the individual I think the important
thing is you have a world where you are
free to achieve whatever ambition you
have and that doesn't have to be tied to
money well I was always led to believe
that markets worked best when they were
transparent when everybody had the same
information
what uber drivers in particular suffer
from is an information arbitrage where
the the operator the platform knows
what's going on but you necessarily do
not you're atomized you're by yourself
and you don't know what other colleagues
are making so you don't know what's good
and what's not so good
I think taxing the wealthy taxing people
at the higher end of the economic
spectrum is not the right way to go
probably sends the wrong message you
know I think what do we want to do we
allocate this ecosystem in this
environment where business can prosper
everybody can prosper and if you put
punitive tax measures in it doesn't work
out you know we could let you spend it
we could let you do you know that the
trickle down is you spend it on
something and they'll spend on something
and it filters out throughout the
economy but no the government think our
we know best and watch they're going to
they waste it you let's have a war in
Iraq let's have a war in Afghanistan
let's have a an IT system in in the NHS
which costs billions of pounds and let's
abandon it they are the waste is
incredible well you seem to have this
idea that you know that what taxation is
the government saying you know put your
hands up give us your money we're having
it actually I think it's the other way
around I think what's happening is if
we're not very careful is that big
businesses become you know have a
parasitic relationship with the state
dealing with uber if it is the boss it
owes the Treasury 1 billion pounds in
v80 and what's our government done
they've allowed them to operate since
2012 without paying v80 without paying
income tax without paying national
insurance it's using our roads 40,000
vehicles for its first five years in
London and Ebers net contribution was
500 pounds per year that's it that is
wrong
so I have to come down on this that I
strongly disagree
I see people working incredibly hard 90
hundred hours a week working themselves
into an early grave and the success does
not come with that and something that
maybe we both can agree upon that if
success was a 100-meter dash you and I
probably start at the 25 to 50 meter
line we already start with advantages
that many other people don't have for
example you went to university I was one
of the few I didn't end up going to
university while everybody else was
having a great time I worked my socks
alright literally didn't do anything but
work I worked harder than anybody I mean
I know and thank God ziz worked because
I'll be pretty sad if it happened
we've honed it on the key area and
that's people on the lower incomes
people that are most vulnerable I think
that the minimum wage is a good thing I
think the way it's increased in recent
years is a good thing you know in my
view want to be you know a low tax read
to be low regulation but high wage
economy but that's regulation in the
right areas and I think good regulation
tends to be regulation you don't notice
but protecting those at the bottom those
who are most vulnerable
I am completely well I'm glad you
appreciate the increase in a minimum
wage we've had over the past few years
but the problem is and you hinter added
here that you don't want too much harsh
enforcement in fact we've had no
enforcement at all and so what we have
is we have some great laws but we have
no enforcement of them and so minimum
wage workers are expected to spend years
in court trying to get that enforced and
that type of a solution is no solution
at all you know and your average typical
uber driver how much does it vary so we
know in New York City where they fell
but something like 30 percent between
2014 and 2017 this is the nature of the
gig economy the platform economy its
oversupply as higher wages flood the
network build a network when you've got
the network monopoly power rail it back
in
can remain neutral because it's a
balance you can't buy happiness I mean
this the notion that can buy happiness
is bonkers but it does and it can and it
make life more exciting and you know
you're only on the pint for a certain
amount of time so I desperately wants to
achieve and you know have the ability
and at least the option to do as many
things that I'd like so that's where I'm
sort of seeing on the fence I suppose I
broadly agree with you about that money
cannot buy happiness but the absence of
money definitely buys you unhappiness
and trouble and problems and social
difficulties I think yeah we've been
very fortunate the business of the ivory
one is done well and that's given
immense opportunity to help others I can
think of all manner of things we've done
whether it's charity work or helping
individual employees you come at this
from the perspective that you can do
good by doing well and to some extent
that's that's true
our model of helping people is one where
we have to do good even if we don't do
well and it's a different motivation I'm
not saying it's it's anymore safely the
playoffs are a little bit different it
does not so less than the nice element
to this people are good people you know
and that is the the live consensus which
can bind people together it's a
willingness to do better to help people
it's been a pleasure definitely stay and
have a drink with you
assuming you're buying
[Applause]